我妈妈就是吵架了，
因为我一直从18岁出来工作之后，
就是我供着弟弟读书，
那已经26岁了，
我每个月基本都会给家里面，
就是连续四年吧，
给爸爸5000块钱，
给妈妈3000~5000，
还给家里面装修了20万左右，
就是之前我们家里面分地的时候，
然后还出了16万买了一块地，
然后我就觉得为家庭付出了很多，
但是呢，
我妈妈就是前段时间他喜欢去打麻将嘛，
我爸爸也说不听，
我对他老婆呢也准备要生了，
然后呢，
就让我去劝一下，
我妈说不要去打麻将了，
因为全家就听我的话，
然后我就跟我妈说，
妈呢，
就是一直骂我，
我就说你要是借钱，
因为她一直都有这个习惯，
后面呢，
就是因为我给姐姐她了，
她就没有去了嘛，
然后现在呢，
他又重新去打样之类的，
我爸他们就叫我跟他说不要去玩了，
然后我就跟他说你喜欢玩也可以，
但是呢，
你要是在外面借了钱了，
我就不会帮你还了，
因为他之前就是有过钱，
然后我帮他呃，
还完了，
他说你给我这点钱买一个这些什么事算什么，
就类似说这种话，
然后我就很伤心，
我就把他给拉黑了，
然后又过了五六天吧，
然后我又把他给。
拉出来了，
拉出来之后他来我公司找我，
然后我当时呢，
我就没有去理他，
然后我觉得我很伤心很生气，
然后还没有缓过来，
我就没有去回应他，
然后他回去之后呢，
就一直觉得是我把他赶回家了，
就没有把他留在公司里面，
不给他面子之类的，
他就骂了100多条语音一直骂我就各种骂，
现在又把他拉黑了，
现在情绪就比较崩溃，
你现在想问的就是怎么处理的他们的关系是不是对我有两个弟弟嘛，
一个弟弟是跟着我一起工作的啊，
年纪也比较小，
18岁这样子，
然后有一个弟弟呢，
他20多岁的老婆友，
怀孕几个月了，
全家呢，
就是只有我跟我小弟该工作了，
然后我爸妈就没有工作，
我跟你讲啊，
有的时候你一味的对一个人，
让他吸你的血，
其实也是害了他，
就比如说你这个弟弟马上要当爸爸了，
你一直是让他趴在你身上来吸血，
其实也是害了他。
理解这个逻辑，
我知道啊，
你需要做的是就是不要让这个人他在我的身上吸我的血，
对，
因为我你的话应该有100个左右，
然后他们就会觉得我很有钱，
然后我自己呢，
也觉得，
哎，
如果这家人好像不好的话，
就心里面会觉得他们很可怜，
是我自己的家庭不是很好。
呃，
18岁的时候谈过一个恋爱，
那个时候我们家是没有钱了，
然后就慢慢的就接触互联网嘛，
然后就开始赚钱了，
因为我妈妈就觉得人家欠了我的钱，
一直以来都觉得啊，
都是因为我给别人花了钱，
才没有把所有的钱给回家里面，
然后肯定一直都有对我有一个这种因为会在里面，
现在要分手了，
现在就是不知道怎么办，
但你是做网络的话，
你住在哪里其实不影响你挣钱，
对吗？
你离你爸妈远一点，
不要跟他们住的很近，
不要让他们能找到你。
如果你这个18岁的弟弟带在身边，
他是一个很懂事，
很懂得感恩的人的话，
就继续带在身边，
如果这个18岁的弟弟也是跟你爸的那个弟弟一样，
只是知道吸你的血，
不懂得感恩的话，
换人就是你。
自己反正是做网络这方面的，
跑到一个最适合做网络的地方去生活，
比如杭州啊，
对吧，
比较发达的这些地方去生活，
然后离原生家庭远一点，
现在反正已经拉黑了嘛，
你要狠心一点。
因为他们之前是有工作的，
然后他们有一次我妈妈有一次受伤之后呢，
我我现得他不要工作了，
我说每个月给你钱，
你不要工作了，
然后现在他就是赌钱，
就受不了这一点，
我就觉得他们好像我说我我问你一个问题啊，
如果现在比如我骂你，
我说你白眼狼，
或者你的家里的亲戚骂你，
说你是眼儿狼，
或者说谁骂你，
说你是白眼狼，
你心里会特别难过，
会特别伤心，
会是怕睡不着吗？
不。
那你就是被人家道德绑架了，
你就是特别想要在亲戚朋友、
网友的面前去证明你自己是一个懂得感恩的人，
是一个对家庭愿意付出的人，
是一个大方的人。
你掉在了这样的人设里面没错吧？
嗯，
你讲啊，
一个懂得感恩，
对家里有回馈这样的人，
他只能是面对那些正常人，
善良的人，
也懂得感恩的人，
才会是一个好的人设。
如果一个懂得感恩，
愿意为家庭付出的人，
他面对的是一群吸血鬼的话，
这个人设反而是一个愚蠢的人设。
人家为什么说愚孝愚忠，
那原因就在这儿，
这个主要看我们对待的那个对象是一个什么样的人，
我们对待的父母是一个什么样的人。
如果我们的父母本身是属于那种很善良，
对儿女的付出都看在眼里的，
对你面觉得幸福感很高，
觉得儿女给他发一点钱，
他每次在亲戚朋友面前都会觉得好幸福呀，
我儿女这么孝顺，
好，
那这就是一个很好的人设，
那如果说嗯，
爸爸妈妈是属于那种吸血鬼，
是属于那种自己不光不挣钱，
还恨不得儿女挣的每一分钱都要交给她，
恨不得儿女的彩礼钱都得给他，
恨不得儿女以后不要给自己的孩子和丈夫花钱，
恨不得自己的女儿以后干的所。
所有的钱都要由他来支配，
由他来保存，
由他来决定花到哪里好，
如果你还是一个孝顺的人设的话，
那完吧，
那就是蠢，
嗯，
诶，
你现在你现在就是这样一个状态，
就是你遇到的爸爸妈妈，
我说句难听点的话，
如果你愿意的话，
恨不得把你账号对吧，
都归他所有，
恨不得把你挣的所有的钱都存到你爸妈名下，
恨不得你爸妈一个月给你3000块钱啊生活费，
那如果这种状态上你还很孝顺，
你还很就是对他们言听计从的话，
那就是蠢，
那样的话就是比较头疼啊，
就是觉得反正就在家里面，
就是什么事情都，
我感觉啊，
人都需要一次阵痛，
就像那个破茧成蝶，
你需要一次阵痛，
这一阵痛就是全给他拉黑，
爱咋咋地，
你需要做的是在这个社会上啊，
老跟你们讲一个道理啊，
这个道理我再给你们讲一遍，
就并不是说谁生了你，
谁就是你的亲人，
不是的，
是谁在这个社会上你遇到的那些人当中，
谁是那个真心盼望你越来越好，
谁是那个真心待你，
为你好，
真心为你着想的那个人，
才可能是你精神上的妈妈，
谁能够在人生的道。
路上，
像你这样的女孩子，
人生的道路你的能见度是很低的，
因为你的爸爸妈妈没有能力指引你往前走，
你需要找的是像一盏灯一样，
在你的人生的前方，
可以指引你往正确的方向去走，
那样的人才是你精神上的妈妈，
当然他们再来影响你的心绪啊，
你像你一年能挣100多万，
你要是把所有的时间精力不是耗费在跟亲人的关系，
不是耗费在这些乱七八糟的亲戚的关系当中的话，
你是不是还能好好的招几个团队，
看能不能搞几个小号，
看能不能搞点切片，
你是不是有可能一年能挣200挣300。